eu trabalhei como palhaço do hospital
durante três anos e meio da minha vida e
o palhaço me ensinou muita coisa é
principalmente a olhar para as pessoas
como isso vai funcionar por exemplo
sempre que um ser humano se relaciona
com outra pessoa é sempre dentro de uma
hierarquia já construída por exemplo o
aluno que conversa com o professor a mãe
que conversa com o filho sei lá marido
esposa o patrão funcionária existe
sempre uma relação social envolvida
isso é sujo isso muitas vezes é tão
empoeirado
eu percebi que com o palhaço a relação é
sempre um palhaço pessoa não importa
quem é essa pessoa
o palhaço tem o poder de olhar no olho e
destruir toda a hierarquia no hospital
eu pude perceber que as pessoas que são
considerados invisíveis por exemplo as
mulheres que varrem o hospital ela
sempre tem uma roupa que não é para
chamar a atenção uma roupa que combina
com a parede como se o objetivo fosse
com que ela ficasse invisível naquele
lugar e assim hotel e assim qualquer
outro lugar
a gente quer tornar as pessoas
invisíveis ninguém pode ver no hotel
quando foi no hotel a mulher tem que
limpar o quarto quando ninguém está
vendo que eu assumi um mágico assim o
palhaço ele chega nessa pessoa que o
mundo coloca por baixo e ele se
ridiculariza esse ridicularizando
enaltece a outra pessoa
só que da mesma maneira quando o dono do
hospital chegava na gente os médicos
cirurgião querendo pagar de gatão o
palhaço ridicularizavam a ele por que
você não pode ser mais engraçado que o
palhaço não adianta você tentar o
palhaço nivel as pessoas no olho e eu
sempre me questionei para que serve a
arte e para que serve a vida e eu vou
contar uma história vocês uma
experiência que foi por pelo por essa
experiência que me chamaram pra mim aqui
na verdade
o grupo que a gente trabalhava a gente
trabalhava em dupla nunca sozinho pra
você a entrar num quarto do hospital
sozinho e às vezes está acontecendo
alguma coisa e sei lá se é bom tem dupla
e nunca em 3 porque senão seria muita
gente dentro do quarto do hospital
sempre em dupla e é sempre um palhaço
mais experiente junto com o palhaço - o
experiente e um meio que vai liderando
as brincadeiras e outro meio que vai
acompanhando e fazendo aquela dinâmica
de palhaço
eu tinha acabado de começar a fazer
trabalho no hospital e depois de um mês
pela primeira vez me colocaram como
sendo o palhaço mais experiente
parece que vai liderar o quarto e
colocar junto comigo uma iniciante uma
menina que nunca tinha feito palhaço do
hospital não tinha que meio que encabeça
a coisa toda e eu gosto de fazer
pediatria eu adorava trabalhar com
criança para criança né
e eu tive maquiado e eu cheguei na
pediatria
a enfermeira me pegou pelo braço foi o
palhaço tem uma missão para você é ter
uma menina que ela está no quarto tipo
sei lá 14 e é o seguinte ela não precisa
de médico nem de enfermeiro nem de
fisioterapeuta além de exame
ela precisa de um palhaço
o nome de alexia ela tem 13 anos e
câncer terminal
alex vai fazer uma cirurgia no final da
semana e eu pela minha experiência de
enfermeira sei que muito provavelmente
ela não vai sobreviver vai lá palhaço e
aí
fazer aquelas brincadeiras que eu tinha
e pegadinhas caíram por terra porque o
que eu aprendi a falar no hospital era
falar de esperança era falar de alegria
e eu falei tá e aí eu abri a porta do
quarto
foi um choque e fechei e falei com a
minha dupla cara você vai ver a coisa
mais extraordinária que você já viu em
sua vida
o aporte foi a cena seguinte tinha o
leito da paciente era só ela no quarto
seja vingança
essas fotos de anorexia de internet de
modelos
ela era muito magra muito pele osso e
mais nada era anoréxica mesmo toda
careca sem pêlos da sobrancelha nem nada
e cheio de tumores espalhados pela
cabeça
detalhe era a última semana de vida da
alexia e não tinha nenhum familiar no
quarto ela tava sozinho eu entrei no
quarto e eu queria falar para ela não
tinha mágica não tinha nada e eu fui
andando em direção a ela e eu peguei na
mão dela e falei alex boi era meu louco
e um momento que eu peguei na mão de
alex é que olho no olho dela era como se
o mundo hierro lá fora tivesse parado no
tempo
não tinha mais enfermeira conversando no
corredor não tinha mais trânsito não
tinha mais nada o relógio na parede
parou e o silêncio era absoluto
a minha dupla me olhou o tipo que vai
fazer a mágica da cordinha o baralho não
faz sentido e olho no olho da lex eu
falei alexia
eu vim aqui da minha casa na verdade eu
vim fazer uma pergunta você gosta
de diversão a minha dupla neurótico que
vamos lá eu fui alex de parque de
diversão parte da versão normal gosto
não tá entendendo alexia se gosta muito
de parque de diversão se apaixonada por
diversão eu gosto pra caramba de
pagamento não alex gosta muito tipo
muita coisa mais legal do mundo à parte
de direção na qual é um parque de
diversão ferrari
então peguei alexia eu vou te contar uma
história e se eu te contasse que existe
um parque de diversão uma época de
diversão que vem aqui me enganar um
parque de diversão tipo disney não tipo
disney a disney é o banheiro do parque
de diversão quanto falam tamanho
magnitude pensou aléxia ela voltou
pensando foi alex quer que você pensa
que nesse parque de diversão se tem uma
suíte master com um tapete com um veludo
uma cama um lustre o banheiro do quarto
que você tem no parque de diversão como
é que ele tem uma banheira de nutella
você pode maravilhosa ali deslizando
nutella está conseguindo alex e sentir
tô
alex e pensa que assistamos o quarto
leilão de plasma totalmente negócio você
abre a porta e você pisa na piscina ele
só chegou parque aquático pensou alexia
pensei
alexia viaja comigo está pensando nisso
alex voltou a falhar
para que existe esse parque existe
e mais uma coisa eu trouxe uma passagem
pra você
prince parque só tem uma coisa
o avião saiu
sua cirurgia
só que é de graça
se você falar que quer te dou te apago
você vai no dia da cirurgia ea melhor
notícia é que você não volta nunca mais
vai ter mais exame tira sangue não tem
nada disso alex equipe principal que
alex
ela sorriu e disse quero eu falei eu
estou te dando essa passagem mas no meu
nome não todos nós
nesse lugar e orei com ela foi embora
eu só acho que hoje ela nadando nutella
ouvindo essa história mas a questão não
é se o céu existe ou não não é essa a
questão
a questão é a que serve a arte a arte
serve da esperança e para abençoar
pessoas
hoje eu não faço mais palhaço porque um
meu amigo que trabalhava comigo que me
ensinou a ser palhaço que tinha a
companhia de teatro cómico faleceu num
acidente de carro
então não consigo mais fazer palhaço mas
eu me encontrei na poesia no sentido da
poesia eo sentido da arte e o sentido da
vida é dar sentido para a vida de alguém
muito obrigado